now that we have our tile sets parse we
need a way to find the image and
coordinate position of a specific tile
in a tile set from our data array now to
do this we're going to have to create a
new function called get tile packet it
takes the index value we want from the
data array of a layer and returns an
object like you see here with the
parameters of image set to the atlas
image and then px and py set to the
x-index and y-index of the tile in the
atlas to grab the specific tile we want
we first need to load through all of the
atlases in the tile sets array checking
the first gid of each one if our first
gid parameter is less than or equal to
the tile index that we're given in this
function then we know that the tile
we're looking for exists in that tile
set once we have the correct tile set we
can grab the tileset image and compute
the necessary offset for the specific
tile we want based on first gid the
number of tiles for cross and down and
the size of the individual tile this
should be some easy math to determine
the x and y value you need